personal shopper is directed by Olivier
Assayas I hope I pronounce his name
correctly and he recently made clouds of
SILS Maria with Juliette Binoche and
Kristen Stewart which I thought was
really good didn't get a chance to
review that on my channel but I
definitely recommend it this film is an
amalgamation of a lot of different
things it's a ghost story it's a story
about Greece it's a story about someone
frustrated in their job it's also a
stalker movie and at the center of all
of these various stories is Kristen
Stewart who plays marine a girl who is a
personal shopper for a very well-known
model in Paris but at the same time
she's recently lost her twin brother in
death and she's trying to reach out to
him to see if he's there if they can
make a connection between life and
afterlife this is a highly
unconventional movie I honestly have
never seen one like it if you go into
this movie expecting a ghost movie with
Kristen Stewart you're going to be
disappointed if you just want to watch a
stereotypical ghost movie with Kristen
Stewart go watch the messenger's you'll
get what you want
this movie is an arthouse film it's a
very very weird odd different movie
there really is nothing else I've ever
seen like it and a lot of it has to do
with those differing tones at one point
in the movie the character of marine
will be feeling ashamed of herself
because she wants to try on these
dresses that she can't afford that she
is buying for this famous model and then
they'll be these really elongated
sequences where she's receiving cryptic
text messages from somebody and it's
very unnerving and then she'll be trying
to connect with a ghost and where the
film harnesses all of these things into
one specific theme is the way the film
traverses the idea of what you go
through when you're grieving and that's
really what this film is about the way
your brain is when you're grieving the
fact that you do stupid things you do
dumb things you think weird things you
don't understand what life is anymore
when you're going through a grieving
process and it's captured extremely well
in the mishmash of tones and I think
that's what the director was going for
and if he was he pulled it off very well
because at first one of my biggest flaws
with this movie while watching it was
the way Maureen was react
getting to these very stalkerish texts
she just kind of went with the flow and
she did things that the texts are asking
her to do and I'm like girl you need to
get the out of there you need to
not be responding this person go to the
police right now and at first I was like
this is stupid
but when you look at the story from the
aspect of somebody who is going through
considerable grief who also I don't want
to get into spoilers but there's also
something that Maureen is dealing with
as a character that really really weighs
on her mind in regards to what she also
dealt with with her brother dying and so
from that perspective I understand why
the decisions this character is going to
make are not going to be the smartest
the most enlightened choices and it
really got under my skin and what I
found so captivating about this movie is
that you can't predict it from scene one
it's totally original there's nothing
about this film that feels like
something I've seen before you can't
really know where it's going and the
film pretty much subverts all
expectations when it comes to watching a
mystery unfold on the screen we're used
to getting puzzle piece shots that shot
that makes you go oh I get what I get
what happened like everything makes
sense now we're used to seeing that in
movies and it's a way that the audience
can kind of connect with the characters
and understand the story the director in
this film almost every chance he gets
doesn't give you the puzzle piece shot
he shows you a sequence and just says
figure it out use your brain and you
have to and it was just so refreshing
just so refreshing to see that this is
yet another film that received boos at
the Cannes Film Festival that I like I
think my new rule of thumb is if critics
booed this film at the Cannes Film
Festival I want to see it right now and
last but not least this is Kristen
Stewart's best performance to date she
is phenomenal in this movie so real
there was a time on my channel when I
used to have to defend myself for saying
that I thought Kristen Stewart was a
good actress that time has passed
she's amazing in this film and I think
it's her best work so far I'm going to
give personal shopper and a
- also just a side note some people were
complaining that it's a ghost movie
called personal shopper it's a dumb
title it's actually the perfect title if
this movie was called a Paris ghost
story or something everyone would go to
it just expecting it to be like the
conjuring and everyone would hate it the
fact that it's called personal shopper
it's going to kind of weed out that
crowd it's a good choice I think III
don't know
movie is weird go see it also my
promotion with audible is still going on
if you guys go to audible.com slash Kris
you can get a free audiobook and a free
30-day trial this is a fantastic service
with so many amazing audiobooks that are
all over that website they have all the
Star Wars legacy novels on there which
is a big thing for me because I love
those books and I really hope you guys
check this service out you can download
so many amazing audiobooks to your mp3
player your phone your computer your
tablet listen to it on the go on an
airplane it's incredibly convenient and
a lot of people have thanked me for this
service some people were even able to
get some of their textbooks for school
through this so I really appreciate that
please do go to audible.com slash Kris
for that free 30-day trial and a free
audio book of your choice and thank you
very much to audible for continuing to
sponsor my videos you guys are the best
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck my knives
[Music]